This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vidantam. Today on the show, we're looking at things that are not what they seem. Authenticity is a trait we all prize. We all want the real thing, whether that's a designer purse or a loving relationship. But the two stories you'll hear today raise profound questions about authenticity and the nature of human belief. If you believe something is real, if you can fall in love with someone or stand in awe of a painting, is it possible that it doesn't actually matter
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。今天的节目中，我们要探讨那些表里不一的事物。真实是我们所有人珍视的品质。我们都渴望得到真实的东西，无论是名牌手袋还是真挚的感情。但你今天听到的两个故事，引发了关于真实性和人类信仰本质的深刻问题。如果你相信某样东西是真的，如果你能爱上某个人或对一幅画肃然起敬，那么有没有可能，其实并不重要
whether the object of your affection is fake? In the second half of our show, we'll explore the art of forgery with the tale of a painter who tricks the world's greatest art experts into believing they are looking at masterpieces. First though, the story of a bald-ing middle-aged man who impersonates women and caunts thousands of other men to fall in love with his creations.
你倾心倾力的对象究竟是不是假的？在节目的后半部分，我们将通过一个画家的故事来探索造假艺术，这个画家欺骗了世界上最伟大的艺术专家，让他们相信自己看到的是旷世杰作。不过首先，我们要讲一个关于中年秃顶男子冒充女性，并诱使数千名其他男子爱上他所创造的虚拟形象的故事。
It's a con that unfolded very slowly over the course of two decades. I first reported the story for an episode of this American life called The Heart Wands What It Wants. The thing that fascinated me most about the story is that when the con was finally exposed, many of the victims were heartbroken. They wanted it to go on. They wanted to keep believing. to keep believing. So here's how the con worked. Guys around the country signed up for a penpal service. It would put them in touch with women they could be friend and carerspot with.
这是一场历时二十年、进展非常缓慢的骗局。我最初是为《美国生活》的一期名为《心之所欲》的节目报道这个故事的。这个故事最令我着迷的地方在于，当骗局最终被揭穿时，许多受害者都心碎了。他们希望骗局继续下去。他们想要继续相信。所以，这个骗局是这样运作的。全国各地的男士们注册了一项笔友服务。这能让他们与可以结为朋友并与之通信的女性取得联系。
And then they'd start to receive letters. They come from Hillsdale, Illinois, and some of them are white, pink, green. Jesse is a sweet, soft-spoken man with thick plastic aviator glasses. He started receiving the letters in 1985 when he was in his 30s. Back then, he was overweight. He'd never had a serious girlfriend, always lived with his parents. After his mother died, he spent most of his time taking care of his sick dad and working
然后他们就会开始收到信件。它们来自伊利诺伊州的希尔斯代尔，其中一些是白色的、粉红色的、绿色的。杰西是一个温和、轻声细语的男子，戴着厚厚的塑料飞行员眼镜。他在1985年三十多岁时开始收到这些信件。那时，他超重了。他从来没有过正经女朋友，一直和父母住在一起。母亲去世后，他大部分时间都在照顾生病的父亲，并在
at his family's restaurant. Jesse's favorite letters came from a woman named Pamela. I, yes, I usually took it at the end of the day when I got him in the mail, went into my room, and laid on my bed and just sat there and read him. Dear Jesse, deep down you know as well as I do that you could be a lot better off than you are if you only had someone on your side. Someone who would help you encourage you, work with you, and stick with you even when things get bad.
家族餐厅里工作。杰西最喜欢的信件来自一个叫帕梅拉的女人。我，是的，我通常在一天结束时拿到信件，走进房间，躺在床上，坐在那里读着它们。亲爱的杰西，内心深处你和我一样清楚，如果你身边能有一个人，你的生活本可以过得更好。一个会帮助你、鼓励你、与你并肩作战，即使情况糟糕也对你不离不弃的人。
What I'm talking about of course is a true friend, but that kind of person is hard to find today isn't it. Jessie had never met or talked to Pamela, but he was curious. He wrote back, telling her a little about himself, and Pamela replied again and again. The letters were typed in a Gullich font and signed in a blue pen with big, gloopy letters. In another letter, Pamela wrote, just before I sat down to write this letter to you, I was thinking how lucky I am that in this great,
我说的当然是一个真正的朋友，但这种人在今天是很难找到的，不是吗？杰西从未见过或交谈过帕梅拉，但他很好奇。他回信了，向她讲述了自己的一些情况，而帕梅拉一次又一次地回复。信是用Gullich字体打印的，并用一支带有大团墨迹的蓝笔签名。在另一封信中，帕梅拉写道，就在我坐下来给你写这封信之前，我在想我是多么幸运，在这个伟大、
big, crazy world I found you. I hope I can be part of your life for a long time, darling, and I hope as time goes by, I'll be able to make you happier and happier. This mystery woman seemed to know him. She made Jesse feel understood. She made him feel loved. You can tell when you made a person that they're not superficial, this is coming from their heart.
宏大而疯狂的世界里找到了你。我希望我能长时间地成为你生活的一部分，亲爱的，我希望随着时间的推移，我能让你越来越幸福。这个神秘的女人似乎很了解他。她让杰西感到被理解。她让他感到被爱。你能看出当你遇到一个人时，他们不是表面化的，这是发自内心的。
Everybody's looking for that perfect love and everything. And this pops up, so I thought, well, could this be something different? This was Pamela. He was mid-laid, balding, and had a small grey moustache. His real name was Gone Lowry. Was any of it difficult to come up with these characters that the characters bore you? Tell me about it as a writing project. No, I look at a 40-grabber girl and say, what kind of girl is this? Where is she from? Where is she like to do?
每个人都在寻找那种完美的爱情什么的。而这个突然出现，所以我想，嗯，这会不会是某种不同的东西？这就是帕梅拉。他中年发福，谢顶，留着一撮灰白的小胡子。他的真名是唐·洛瑞。要想出这些角色有什么困难吗，这些角色会让你厌烦吗？作为一个写作项目，跟我讲讲吧。不，我看着一个四十多岁的女孩，说，这是个什么样的女孩？她是从哪里来的？她喜欢做什么？
It was fairly easy after a while. The first 20 were a little bit rough, but the next 80 were not hard at all. Anyway, enjoyed making up these characters. I loved it. Yeah, I loved it. I loved it. I loved that. Don died in 2014, but I met him in 2011 in a rundown house in Butler, Pennsylvania. He was 82.
过了一段时间这就变得相当容易了。前20个有点艰难，但接下来的80个一点也不难。不管怎样，我很享受捏造这些角色。我太喜欢了。是的，我喜欢。我喜欢。我太喜欢了。唐在2014年去世了，但我是在2011年宾夕法尼亚州巴特勒的一栋破旧房子里见到了他。他当时82岁。
If you have trouble understanding Don's voice, it's because he was a lifelong heavy smoker. The desk in his living room was covered with ash, his sofa smelled of smoke. Don told me he always wanted to be a writer, but his real talent wasn't being a hustler. He always had a scheme going. In his early thirties Don visited Mexico and wrote a traveler's guide where he explained how American men could live cheaply there, pick up women, and get by with rudimentary Spanish. It was called Mexico backwards paradise. It didn't sell. And then he tried something most writers would never consider. He changed the name called mechagol backwards paradise. It didn't sell.
如果你听不懂唐的声音，那是因为他是个老烟枪。他客厅的桌子上布满了烟灰，他的沙发散发着烟味。唐告诉我，他一直想成为一名作家，但他真正的天赋不是当作家，而是当一个投机倒把的人。他总是有各种点子。三十出头时，唐访问了墨西哥，并写了一本旅行指南，解释美国人如何在当地廉价生活、泡妞，以及用蹩脚的西班牙语混日子。这本书叫《墨西哥逆向天堂》。它没有卖出去。然后他尝试了大多数作家绝不会考虑的事情。他把书的作者名字改成了女性的名字。
And then he tried something, most writers would never consider. He changed the name of the book's author to a woman's name. Sales開rocketed, he said. Apparently, lonely American men didn't want tips from a guy. They wanted tips from a girl. Don realized there was a market waiting to be exploited. He rented mailing lists for magazines
然后他尝试了大多数作家绝不会考虑的事情。他把书的作者名字改成了女性的名字。据他说，销量暴增。显然，孤独的美国人不想接受一个男人的建议。他们想要一个女孩的建议。唐意识到有一个等待被开拓的市场。他租用了杂志的邮寄名单，
that cater to single men and started writing letters to them posing as different women. Men like Jesse were invited to join a club where, in exchange for a small fee, they could receive love letters. In a moment of inspiration, Don decided to call the women who wrote the letters Angels. Angel Linda, Angel Christina, Angel Pamela. He purchased stock photos of models and printed catalogs with photos and bios for each angel. Angels came in different flavors. Some were
这些杂志迎合单性男性的需求，并开始以不同女性的身份给他们写信。像杰西这样的男人被邀请加入一个俱乐部，在那里，只需支付少量费用，他们就可以收到情歌般的信件。在灵感闪现的时刻，唐决定将写信的女性称为“天使”。天使琳达，天使克里斯蒂娜，天使帕梅拉。他购买了模特的库存照片，并为每个天使印制了带有照片和个人简介的目录。天使们风格各异。有些是
compliant, helpless and pure, others were raunchy and sent nude photos of themselves. Most were young and all were eager to please. Dream women, for a certain kind of man, dreamed up of course, by another man. In one brochure Angel Linda Scott is pictured in a one-piece swimsuit on her hands and knees. Angel Christina looks like an idealistic woman. She's shown hugging a tree and holding a flower. I prefer a certain type of man, Christina says. He can pick up a handful of dark, rich soil and feel a kind of reverence and joy.
顺从、无助且纯洁的，另一些则很色情，会寄出自己的裸照。大多数都很年轻，而且都急于取悦他人。对于某种类型的男人来说，她们是梦想中的女性，当然，是由另一个男人梦想出来的。在一份宣传册中，天使琳达·斯科特身着连体泳衣，双手双膝着地。天使克里斯蒂娜看起来像个理想主义女性。她被拍到拥抱一棵树并拿着一朵花。克里斯蒂娜说：“我更喜欢某种类型的男人。”他可以抓起一把黑色的、肥沃的泥土，感受到一种敬畏和喜悦。
But he's awfully hard to find. Don mailed his brochures to men like Jesse. If a man wrote back, Don began sending letters to him as Angel Christina or Angel Linda. Don told me he didn't want members who were just looking for sex. He wanted men looking for meaningful relationships who would be in it for the long haul. sex. He wanted men looking for meaningful relationships who would be in it for the long hall. He thought this would be better for business and better for the marks. Yeah, the guy is his wife died, you know, and he was living alone. He didn't have any friends. You know, that kind of thing. He needed this. He didn't have anything or anybody else to turn him up. Nobody. We do.
但他实在很难找到。唐把他的宣传册寄给像杰西这样的男人。如果有人回信，唐就开始以天使克里斯蒂娜或天使琳达的身份给他回信。唐告诉我，他不想找那些只为了寻求性的人。他想要那些寻找有意义的、能够长久持续的关系的男人。性。他想要那些寻找有意义的、能够长久持续的关系的男人。他认为这对外生意更好，对这些冤大头也更好。是的，这个家伙的妻子死了，你知道的，他一个人住。他没有任何朋友。你知道，诸如此类的事情。他需要这个。他没有其他任何人或事可以依靠。谁也没有。我们有。
These girls would boost their egos. Things like, all your handwriting is so masculine. Things like that. The little things. Give the guy a boost. And they loved it. After a few letters to Jessie, Pamela let him know that the only thing she wanted was a little help.
这些女孩会提升他们的自尊心。比如，你的笔迹真有男子气概。诸如此类的话。微小的事情。给这家伙打打气。而他们很喜欢。在给杰西写了信件后，帕梅拉让他知道，她唯一想要的就是一点小小的帮助。
Darling, I want you to know that I really love writing you every day. It has filled a great need in my life and I know I'd be very sad if I had to stop writing you and being your friend. I hope you feel the same way about me and my letters to you. I think it's fair and reasonable for me to ask you to help with the expensive paper, envelopes, postage, photos, and the other things I'll be sending you. If you could send me just $10 a week for my letters, I could continue writing every day as I have been.
亲爱的，我想让你知道，我真的很喜欢每天给你写信。这填补了我生活中的巨大需求，我知道如果我不得不停止给你写信、停止做你的朋友，我会非常难过。我希望你对我以及我对你的信件也有同样的感受。我认为我要求你帮我承担昂贵的纸张、信封、邮资、照片以及我将寄给你的其他东西的费用，是公平且合理的。如果你能每周只寄给我10美元作为信件费用，我就可以像以前一样继续每天写作。
Jesse was fine with that. He figures he sent in four or five thousand dollars between 1985 and 88. It wasn't a big deal to him. My business was prospering pretty well. We ran over $100,000, three years in a row, so there was no problem for me to be sending money and stuff, so. Pamela often sent Jesse's stories about the two of them for a little extra money. In one, Pamela and Jesse go on a picnic together.
杰西觉得这没问题。他估计自己在1985年到1988年间寄出了四五千美元。这对她来说不是什么大不了的事。我的生意相当兴隆。我们连续三年销售额超过10万美元，所以对我来说寄钱之类的根本没有问题，所以。帕梅拉经常给杰西寄一些关于他们两个人的小故事，以换取一点额外的钱。在一个故事中，帕梅拉和杰西一起去野餐。
In another, he literally rescues her as a knight in shining armor. This one story that has them both lying on a bear skin rug in front of a fireplace. And of course, it goes where you think it will go if two people are lying on a bear skin rug in front of a fireplace. But it's romantic. Not explicit. The language is tame. The letter concludes, I lay beside you and whispered goodnight my sweet darling. Let us drift away to paradise in our dreams and wake up together to a new and wonderful day. I kiss you gently and fall asleep in your arms.
在另一个故事中，他真的像一个身披闪亮铠甲的骑士一样拯救了她。这个故事里他们俩都躺在壁炉前的熊皮地毯上。当然，如果两个人躺在壁炉前的熊皮地毯上，事情就会向你想的那样发展。但这很浪漫。并不露骨。语言很温和。信的结尾写道：“我躺在你身边，轻声说晚安，我亲爱的甜心。让我们在梦中漂向天堂，一起醒来迎接崭新美好的一天。我温柔地吻你，在你的怀里睡去。”
Okay, obviously cheesy. Don Lowry was not a gifted writer, but he was a gifted manipulator. When I first heard about the story, I assumed the men who signed up for the letters from the angels must have been such easy marks, so naive. Who else would buy such absurd fantasies? But then I read the dozens and dozens of letters that Pamela sent Jesse. He saved them in a large binder, each letter in its own plastic sleeve. And as I read the letters, I started to understand the power of the psychological tools Don used to hook men like Jesse. Most of the letters aren't epic fantasies. Most are about the minutia of Pamela's
好吧，显然很老套。唐·洛瑞不是一个有天赋的作家，但他是一个极具天赋的操纵者。当我第一次听到这个故事时，我以为那些报名接收天使来信的男人一定很容易被骗，太天真了。谁会买账这么荒谬的幻想呢？但后来我读了帕梅拉写给杰西的成百上千封信。他把它们存放在一个大文件夹里，每封信都有自己的塑料封套。当我阅读这些信件时，我开始理解唐用来钩住杰西这样男人的心理工具的力量。大多数信件都不是史诗般的幻想。大多数都是关于帕梅拉生活中微不足道的小事。
life. She goes to the bank, she talks to coworkers, she tells Jesse her thoughts on televangelis. Over and over, Pamela tells Jesse how much he means to her. She praises him, encourages him. When you read the letters one after the other, like Jesse did day after day after day, it paints a picture that feels real. I felt the Pamela and the letters was a real person, and I knew Don was writing them. There were other tricks. In one letter, Pamela asked Jesse to keep a picture of hers nearby as he read her letters so he would feel she was in the room with him. Jessie put up two photos of her on the wall.
她去银行，和同事聊天，她告诉杰西她对电视布道者的看法。帕梅拉一次又一次地告诉杰西他对她有多重要。她赞美他，鼓励他。当你像杰西那样日复一日地连续阅读这些信件时，它描绘出了一幅感觉真实的画面。我觉得信中的帕梅拉是一个真实的人，而我知道是唐在写这些。还有其他的把戏。在其中一封信中，帕梅拉让杰西在读信时把她的照片放在附近，这样他就会觉得她和他在同一个房间里。杰西把她的两张照片贴在墙上。
She once sent him a dime. In that letter she told Jessie she had just had a strange day. Another driver bashed her car but didn't leave a note. Just when it looked like the day couldn't get any worse, she lost her purse. Depressed Pamela spotted this very dime on the street. She picked it up, hoping it was a lucky charm. Later, a little boy showed up with her purse. A woman called and took responsibility for the car.
她曾寄给他一毛钱。在信中，她告诉杰西她刚刚度过了奇怪的一天。另一个司机撞了她的车，却没有留便条。正当事情看起来不能再糟的时候，她弄丢了钱包。沮丧的帕梅拉在街上发现了这枚硬币。她捡起它，希望它是个幸运符。后来，一个小男孩拿着她的钱包出现了。一个女人打电话为车祸承担责任。
Pamela told Jessie she was giving him her lucky dime. Here's Jessie reading from the end of that letter. Keep this dime darling. Letters always remind you that good people can still come into your life, and good things can still happen to you, and also think of this as a small token of my affection for you. If you hold it in your hand and squeeze it hard, you'll feel the warmth of my love coming out of it. Did you actually do that, Jesse?
帕梅拉告诉杰西，她要把她幸运的一毛钱送给他。这里是杰西朗读那封信的结尾。留着这枚硬币吧，亲爱的。信件总是提醒你，好人仍然可以走进你的生活，美好的事情仍然会发生在你身上，也请把这当作我倾心于你的一个小小信物。如果你把它握在手里，用力捏紧，你就会感受到我的爱从中散发出来的温暖。杰西，你真的那样做了吗？
Yes, I think I did do that and everything. Like I said, Jesse's mother had recently died and his dad had heart trouble. He spent a lot of time looking after him. He wrote letters to Pamela confiding in her about his depression. She sent him heartfelt letters about bad relationships she'd had, and she told him about visiting her grandfather who was suffering from dementia. That really took its toll on her, so I kind of bonded with that, knowing that she was going through the same thing that I was me and her kind of more or less bonded more than any
是的，我想我确实那样做了，诸如此类。就像我说的，杰西的母亲最近去世了，他的父亲有心脏病。他花了很多时间照顾他。他给帕梅拉写信，向她倾诉自己的抑郁。她给他写了深情的信，讲述了她经历过的糟糕关系，她还告诉他关于探望患有痴呆症的祖父的事。那真的对她造成了很大的打击，所以我对那种经历产生了共鸣，我知道她经历的事情和我正在经历的是一样的，我和她之间的某种联系比我交谈过的任何其他人都多。
other person I've ever talked to. It was kind of like a beacon from outside. It was like if you were a ship out at sea and you were looking for a light house, which they used that in the deal to look for the light and everything and guide yourself towards it where you know that you'll have safe haven. I'm not sure I'm exactly following you. Is this something from one of the letters where they basically talk about the lighthouse? Yes, and in fact, I got a little wooden figure of a lighthouse that she sent to me at one time
这就像是来自外界的一盏明灯。这就好比如果你是一艘在海上航行的船，你在寻找一座灯塔——他们在这笔生意里也用过这个比喻，寻找明灯并引导自己驶向它，在那里你知道自己将拥有一个安全的避风港。我不太确定我完全理解你的意思。这是信件里提到灯塔的某段内容吗？是的，事实上，她有一次送给我一个小木头灯塔雕像，
and everything. So let this be can know that somebody's out there looking out for you and everything. If Jesse had wanted to see it, there were plenty of signs the letters were mass-produced. They looked typed, but the paper doesn't have the indentations that come from tie-priter keys. The signatures look like they've been stamped or printed. All the specifics in the letters are about Pamela's life. In the letters did Pamela ever ask you how you were handling your mom's death? Not that I remember, no, I don't think so. Did she ask how your dad's health was? Not that I remember at this time, no.
诸如此类。所以这盏明灯意味着外面有人在照顾你，诸如此类。如果杰西想看的话，有足够的迹象表明这些信件是批量生产的。它们看起来像是打印的，但纸张没有打字机按键留下的压痕。签名看起来像是被盖章或打印出来的。信件中的所有细节都是关于帕梅拉生活的。在信中，帕梅拉有没有问过你你是如何应对妈妈的去世的？据我所记得的，没有，我想没有。她有没有问过你爸爸的健康状况？据我所记得的当时没有，没有。
In fact, when I read Pamela's letters to Jessie, she never mentions any of the things he's told her. When Pamela talks about Jessie's life, she switches into generalities. I know you're sad, I know you're lonely, I know you're having a hard time. The only way the letters are personalized is that Jessie's name is sprinkled throughout, out of filled, like a madlib sheet. To Jessie, it didn't matter. He saw what he wanted to see.
事实上，当我读帕梅拉写给杰西的信时，她从来没有提及任何他告诉过她的事情。当帕梅拉谈到杰西的生活时，她转为了泛泛而谈。我知道你很伤心，我知道你很孤独，我知道你正经历艰难时期。信件唯一被个性化的地方就是杰西的名字被点缀在各处，像填字游戏纸一样被填进去。对杰西来说，这并不重要。他看到了他想看的东西。
At the time, I wasn't really fully absorbing all of that. I had a lot of my plate kind of in turmoil with everything that was going on. So I just read them and it kind of took some encouragement, encouragement out of it. Did you ever have doubts about what was going on as you were receiving the letters? Well, no, not at the time and everything. Like I said, I was glad to be getting letters from somebody and even though you're paying money for that, because you have blinders on and not really paying attention to all of that. Like I said, when you're not the best-looking person in the world,
当时，我并没有真正完全消化所有这些。我手头有很多事情，随着发生的一切，一切都乱成一团。所以我只是读了它们，它从中获得了一些鼓励。在收到信件时，你有没有对正在发生的事情产生过怀疑？嗯，没有，当时没有，诸如此类。就像我说的，我很高兴能收到某人的来信，即便你要为此付钱，因为你戴着眼罩，并没有真正注意到所有这些。就像我说的，当你不是世界上长得最好看的人时，
that somebody out of the blue, the right to you, and tell you things and kind of build up your spirits and everything and stuff, because everybody looks at you and stuff. It's kind of like the deal with a hunchback of Notre Dame. You'll never find anybody that'll care for you, but they are at the end. He wound up making a friend with the people that befriended him in everything. At a certain point Pamela became the thing that kept Jesse afloat when he had to work long hours, when he had to close his restaurant and rush his father to the hospital.
竟然会有人突发奇想，给你写信，对你说一些话，并有点振奋你的精神，因为每个人都看着你，诸如此类。这有点像《巴黎圣母院》里那个驼背的故事。你永远找不到会在乎你的人，但他们最后还是找到了。他最终和那些对友好相待的人成了朋友。在某种特定时刻，当杰西不得不长时间工作、不得不关闭餐厅并急忙将父亲送往医院时，帕梅拉成了支撑他活下去的支柱。
when he had to work long hours, when he had to close his restaurant and rush his father to the hospital. I, yes, there was one thing that really kind of touched me in everything I was telling him ready to give up and everything. And she just told me, get back on your feet and everything so that really was a word of encouragement and everything. and everything.
当他不得不长时间工作、不得不关闭餐厅并急忙将父亲送往医院时。我，是的，有一件事真的触动了我，当时我正准备放弃，诸如此类。她只是告诉我，重新站起来，所以那真的是一句鼓励的话，诸如此类。诸如此类。
As Don went on, he realized his members were hooked and he could take the fantasy further. Much further. All kinds of people were members. We even had a priest join the call, really. Wait, this is not a Catholic priest. Yeah, a Catholic priest. Yeah, Catholic priest. What was he hoping to get out of it? Who the hell knows? There's probably this board.
随着唐的继续，他意识到他的会员们已经上钩了，他可以把幻想推得更远。远得多。各种各样的人都是会员。我们甚至有一个牧师加入了邪教，真的。等等，这不是一个天主教牧师。对，一个天主教牧师。对，天主教牧师。他希望从中得到什么？鬼知道呢。可能这就是……
How dawn finally got caught when we come back. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is NPR. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Today's show is about forgers and the victims of forgers. We're exploring the mindset of people who do the duping and the people who get duped. Our first story is about a man named Don Lowry who ran a fake penpal service. He fooled thousands of men into believing they were corresponding with beautiful young
我们回来后将讲述唐是如何最终落网的。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这里是NPR。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。今天的节目是关于造假者和造假者的受害者。我们正在探讨行骗之人和受骗之人的心态。我们的第一个故事是关于一个名叫唐·洛瑞的人，他经营着一个虚假的笔友服务。他欺骗了成千上万的男人，让他们相信自己正在与年轻美丽的女性通信。
women. Over time, many of the men fell in love with Don's inventions. As he ensnared his victims, Don came to understand that human gullibility runs very, very deep. He invented an epic world for his angels with a magical backstory and a fantastic future. Here's how it worked. The angels supposedly lived together in a retreat hidden away from the world, most were lost souls escaping drugs and bad men. These were women who needed a steady hand and a strong shoulder.
随着时间推移，许多男人爱上了唐虚构的人物。在网罗受害者的过程中，唐逐渐明白，人类的轻信程度非常、非常深。他为他的天使们创造了一个史诗般的世界，有着神奇的背景故事和梦幻般的未来。它是这样运作的。据说天使们一起生活在一个与世隔绝的世外桃源里，大多数都是逃避毒品和坏男人的迷失灵魂。这些是需要坚定双手和坚实肩膀的女人。
As he invented more angels, dawn came up with interweaving backstories. Some angels were good, some bad, angels helped one another, backstabbed each other. All the men who signed up to join the Lonely Hats Club understood they were joining an organization of good-hearted men who were devoted to taking care of the angels. The organization was known as the Kha'a. Don promised members of the Kaul that they would one day move with the angels to a valley paradise into a giant building shaped like a naked woman lying down on the grass. This lady-shaped building would house meeting rooms and auditoriums. The paradise was to be called Shandaza.
随着他发明更多的天使，唐想出了相互交织的背景故事。有些天使是好的，有些是坏的，天使们互相帮助，背后捅刀子。所有报名加入“孤独男士俱乐部”的男人们都明白，他们是在加入一个由善良男子组成的组织，这些人致力于照顾天使们。这个组织被称为“卡”。唐向“卡”的成员承诺，他们有一天会和天使们一起搬到一个山谷天堂，搬进一个巨大建筑里，那是一个侧躺在草地上的裸体女性形状的建筑物。这座人形建筑将设有会议室和礼堂。这个天堂将被命名为尚达萨。
In exchange for their contributions, the members would have their needs looked after at Chandaza, all their needs. At the center of the entire fantasy was a matriarch, a saintly woman named Mother Maria. Maria collected and managed the money from the members, and she organized and disciplined the angels. She was set to have mystical powers, and could re-virginize fallen women. There were photos of mother Maria. She was beautiful.
作为回报，他们的贡献将换来在尚达萨的需求得到关照，所有的需求。整个幻想的核心是一个女族长，一个名叫玛丽亚母亲的圣洁女人。玛丽亚收集并管理会员们的资金，她组织并管束天使们。据说她拥有神秘的力量，能够让堕落的女性恢复处女之身。有玛丽亚母亲的照片。她很漂亮。
Maria's photos were actually for a woman named Esther. She was Don's wife. Not all the members of the call believed in Chandaza. Jesse stuffed the letters describing Chandaza in the back pocket of the binder. He figured it was just some wacky idea Pamela had and just ignored it. But there were other fish who found this hook tempting. In my mind, I always held this area of, tried not to be convinced, you know, 100% about it, you know, surely that, you know, it's too good to be true.
玛丽亚的照片其实是一个叫埃丝特的女人。她就是唐的妻子。并非“卡”的所有成员都相信尚达萨。杰西把描述尚达萨的信件塞进了文件夹的后袋里。他觉得这只是帕梅拉的一些古怪想法，于是就忽略了它。但还有其他觉得这个诱饵很诱人的傻瓜。在我的脑海里，我总是保留着这样一片区域，尽量不去确信，你知道，百分之百地相信它，你知道，确信，你知道，这好得让人难以置信。
This is Ken Blanchard. He's a big gentle man and was another member of the call for many years. He was single when he joined, and he was still single when I met him in 2012. What was the draw? What did you tell yourself when you said, you know, this is still good to be true? Well, I think with me it was the prospect of maybe at least having some sort of communication with some women, you know, maybe my age, maybe a little bit too young for me, maybe even then. It sounds like a neat idea to be on the leading edge of something like that. Oh geez, I don't know what else to try to explain my part of it, or belief in it or anything. They got me hooked on what they were saying and everything, and I believed them. Don got hundreds of new signups every year.
这是肯·布兰查德。他是一个身材高大温和的男子，也是“卡”多年的另一位成员。他加入时是单身，2012年我见到他时依然单身。吸引力是什么？当你对自己说“你知道，这好得难以置信”时，你是怎么自我解释的？嗯，我想对我和我来说，前景可能至少是能和一些女性进行某种交流，你知道，也许和我年龄相仿，也许比我稍微年轻一点，甚至可能就是那样。在一个类似这样的前沿事物上当弄潮儿听起来是个不错的主意。哦天哪，我不知道还能怎么解释我这部分，或者对它的信仰什么的。他们让我迷上了他们所说的话，而我相信了他们。唐每年都会获得数百名新注册用户。
Millions of dollars flowed back to Don's headquarters in Molene, Illinois. He bought himself expensive cars, a Rolls Royce, and a Mercedes. He bought his sons and estuars everything they wanted. He got a big office in downtown Molene and operated a print shop. He hired assistants, salespeople, and ghost writers to expand his operation. By the mid-1980s, Don was writing love letters to more than 30,000 men. We had lawyers, doctors, professors, mechanics, bakers, you name it, all kinds of people, remember. We even had a priest join the call. Really?
数百万美元流回了唐位于伊利诺伊州莫林的总部。他给自己买昂贵的汽车，一辆劳斯莱斯和一辆梅赛德斯。他给他的儿子们和埃丝特买了他们想要的一切。他在莫林市中心买了一间大办公室，并经营一家印刷厂。他雇用了助理、销售人员和代笔人来扩展他的业务。到20世纪80年代中期，唐正在给3万多名男性写情书。我们有律师、医生、教授、机械师、面包师，应有尽有，各种各样的人，记住。我们甚至有一个牧师加入了邪教。真的吗？
Wait, that's not a Catholic priest. Yeah, a Catholic priest. What was he hoping to get out of it? Who the hell knows? There was probably this board. To exploit this growing market, Don constantly experimented with news, schemes, and products.
等等，那不是天主教牧师。对，一个天主教牧师。他希望从中得到什么？鬼知道。可能这就是……
He started selling cassette tapes where the angels floteded with the men. He got into merch, monks, puzzles, commemorative coins, all with angels faces printed on them. And we sent out a pillowcase with angel-tariots face on them. It's an angry sleep with angels every night. Oh, we know all things like that. every night. Oh, we know all things I can.
为了开发这个不断增长的市场，唐不断尝试新的计划和产品。他开始出售天使向男人们调情的磁带。他涉足周边商品，马克杯、拼图、纪念币，上面都印着天使的脸。我们还寄出了印有天使塔里奥脸庞的枕套。这是一个每天晚上和天使睡觉的生动例子。哦，我们知道所有诸如此类的事情。每天晚上。哦，我们知道所有类似的事情。
The members won just sending in cash and checks. They were sending gifts. Ken sent Angel Vanessa a windbreaker. Others sent coats and shoes. Even gardening equipment so the angels could grow vegetables at their secret retreat. Did you encourage them to send personal items? No, no. I hated that. Here's the guy, his wife died. And she left all kinds of jewelry and dresses and so on.
会员们不只是寄现金和支票。他们还在寄礼物。肯给天使凡妮莎寄了一件风衣。其他人寄了外套和鞋子。甚至是园艺工具，以便天使们可以在她们的秘密隐居地种菜。你鼓励他们寄个人物品吗？不，不。我讨厌那样。你看这个家伙，他的妻子死了。而她留下了各种珠宝、裙子等等。
I put them in a big cardboard box and mallet to us. What the hell are we going to do with it? Now what you wanted, of course, was you wanted them to send a check. Of course. Or money them to send a check. Of course, or money or a cash or anything. Did you tell them not to do it? Very subtly. I don't want to hurt their feelings. They thought they were doing a great thing for the individuals by saying that these clothes. Anyway, I heard them. My dad would blaze in Leijas. He would have sidewalk sales,
我把它们装进一个大纸箱里，邮寄给我们。我们到底要用它做什么？现在你想要的，当然是你想让他们寄一张支票。当然。或者钱想让他们寄一张支票。当然，或者钱或现金什么的。你告诉他们不要这么做吗？非常含蓄地。我不想伤害他们的感情。他们以为通过寄这些衣服是在为个人做一件伟大的事。不管怎样，我伤害了他们。我爸爸会在莱亚斯搞促销。他会在人行道上搞促销，
lingerie and gifts and jewelry. This is Don Sun, Riko Lauri. And my dad would blaze in Leijas. You'd be selling the lingerie on racks in front of the print shop. He would actually put up racks on the sidewalk in front of the print shop? Yep. Yep. My dad had a very sarcastic and wicked sense of humor.
内衣、礼物和珠宝。这是唐的儿子，里科·洛瑞。我爸爸会在莱亚斯搞促销。你会把内衣挂在印刷厂前的架子上卖。他居然在印刷厂前的人行道上架起货架？对。对。我爸爸有一种非常讽刺且恶劣的幽默感。
A local police officer told me men from all over the country started showing up in Malin, asking where they could find the angels. If they found their way to the print shop, Don called the cops on them. Don found it police tried to explain to the men that there was no angel Vanessa, no retreat, no shondaza. But occasionally, if Don was in the mood, he'd actually allow them to meet female employees whom he had asked to pose as angels in photos. In time, Don even set up events for his most loyal members to meet the angels.
当地的一名警官告诉我，来自全国各地的男士开始出现在莫林，询问他们去哪里可以找到天使。如果他们找到了印刷厂，唐就会报警。唐发现警察试图向这些男人们解释，世上根本没有什么天使凡妮莎，没有隐居地，也没有尚达萨。但偶尔，如果唐有那个心情，他实际上会允许他们见见那些他曾让她们在照片中扮演天使的女员工。随着时间推移，唐甚至为他最忠诚的会员举办了与天使会面的活动。
He called them gatherings. At the gathering in Chicago, an advice columnist offered dating suggestions, a comedian told jokes. Angels and yellow green dresses leapt around on stage in an interpretive dance. Jesse went to the Moline gathering. He was excited to finally meet Pamela. She looked just like she did in her pictures. In fact, she was one of Don's employees, and her name really was Pamela. She greeted Jessie warmly. But Jessie's excitement was tempered by the fact that there were a dozen other men at the gathering. Jessie was shocked to find that every man thought he was in a personal relationship with Pamela too. They crowded around her,
他称之为聚会。在芝加哥的聚会上，一位专栏作家提供了约会建议，一位喜剧演员讲了笑话。穿着黄绿色衣服的天使们在舞台上跳着现代舞蹦蹦跳跳。杰西去了莫林的聚会。他很高兴终于能见到帕梅拉了。她看起来和照片里一模一样。事实上，她是唐的一名员工，她的名字确实叫帕梅拉。她热情地问候了杰西。但杰西的兴奋被一个事实冲淡了，那就是聚会上还有十几个其他的男人。杰西惊讶地发现，每个男人都以为自己也和帕梅拉有着私人恋情。他们挤在她周围，
vying for her attention. And then that's when it dawned on me and said, hey, this is not what I thought it would be or anything. That it was a rip off. Well, that was kind of like getting a kick in the stomach. It was upsetting and everything. We sent all that money in the snout and the other end. It wasn't what it was meant to be.
争夺她的注意力。然后就在那时我恍然大悟，说，嘿，这和我想象的不一样，或者说这就是一场骗局。嗯，那感觉就像肚子上挨了一拳。这令人沮丧，诸如此类。我们把所有的钱都寄过去了，而结果却不是它原本应该成为的样子。
It got you down to reality and stuff, so. Jesse knew that Pamela lacked music boxes, so he bought an expensive one with a tiny record on it that played when the Saints go marching in. Pamela loved it. He says she stared at it and let the record play. It went on and on and on. The other men stood around them and looked at Jesse. They looked at Pamela, then back to Jessie. He liked that he was making them jealous.
这让你面对现实，等等。杰西知道帕梅拉缺少音乐盒，所以他买了一个昂贵的音乐盒，上面有一个小唱片，当《圣徒行进》播放时，它就会旋转。帕梅拉很喜欢它。他说她盯着它看，让唱片一直播放。它一直放，一直放，一直放。其他男人站在他们周围，看着杰西。他们看着帕梅拉，然后又看向杰西。他很享受自己让他们嫉妒的感觉。
Jessie didn't blame Pamela. He wasn't exactly sure how the scam worked, but he was sure that the woman's standing before him was the same woman who wrote to him that she was the one who had read his letters. The proof? Pamela's dog jumped into his lap. She jumped on my lap twice and everything, that really surprised Pamela and that. So I guess she smelled my scent on the letters I was writing to her and everything and stuff. We got in touch with Pamela to see if she remembered any of this, but she declined to be interviewed
杰西不怪帕梅拉。他不是十分确定这个骗局是如何运作的，但他确信眼前这个女人就是给他写信的那个女人，就是读过他信件的那个人。证据呢？帕梅拉的狗跳到了他的大腿上。她跳到我的腿上两次，诸如此类，这真的让帕梅拉很惊讶。所以我想她是从我写给她的信上闻到了我的气味，诸如此类。我们联系了帕梅拉，看她是否还记得这些，但她拒绝接受
on tape for the story. She did confirm that she hadn't written the letters. Jesse made friends with a couple of other men at the meeting, particularly two guys named Lenny and Al. They were all like strangers who had independently watched the same soap opera for many years. Well, we got to talking about it and say, well, why did you write on to this and everything? Instead of bonding with the girls, we ended up talking each other and meeting new friends and talking about the troubles we had.
关于这个故事的磁带采访。她确实证实她没有写过那些信。杰西在聚会上和另外几个男人交朋友，特别是两个叫伦尼和艾尔的家伙。他们就像是一群互不相识却各自独立观看了多年同一部肥皂剧的人。嗯，我们聊了起来，说，嗯，你为什么要写信给这个，诸如此类。我们没有去和女孩们建立联系，反而最终聊起了彼此，结识了新朋友，谈论了我们遇到的麻烦。
So we kind of, well, they were just like me and everything. So we stayed in correspondence like they said. They wrote me letters and they even called me at my restaurant to ask me how things were going and everything. Fanged and out asking about my dad and everything so that kind of was encouraging to hear somebody calling to want to check on you and everything. In other words, they asked about all the personal stuff Pamela never asked about. Lenny announced aid in touch until they died.
所以我们有点，嗯，他们就像我一样，等等。所以我们保持着联系，正如他们所说。他们给我写信，甚至还打到我的餐厅来问我事情进展得怎么样，诸如此类。还打电话来询问我父亲的情况，诸如此类，所以听到有人打电话来关心你，感觉挺鼓舞人心的。换句话说，他们询问了所有帕梅拉从未询问过的私事。伦尼和艾尔直到去世都保持着联系。
What finally brought Don Lowry's camp to an end was a woman named Susan Rassos. She was a model that Don had worked with. She had gotten into a car crash and called Don for help. He showed up at the hospital with a photographer. The unbandaged her wounds and took pictures. They sent these to all the men who were corresponding with the angel Susan and asked them for help in paying her medical bills. But Don didn't give Susan the money.
最终让唐·洛瑞的骗局走向终结的是一个名叫苏珊·拉索斯的女人。她是一个曾与唐合作过的模特。她遭遇了一场车祸，并打电话向唐求助。他带着摄影师出现在医院。他们解开了她的绷带并拍了照片。他们把这些寄给所有与天使苏珊通信的男人们，并请求他们帮助支付她的医疗费用。但唐并没有把钱给苏珊。
She went to the cops. And she came to our office. She revealed the promise that Mr. Lowry had made to her and broken. The return that Mr. Lowry received was staggering in terms of dollars and cents. This is Lieutenant Kenneth Rex Roth of the Malin Police Department. He'd been aware of Don Lowry for years. He turned away many men who'd come to the police station in search of the angels, and he'd been looking for a way to lock Don up. He was very diabolical. He's a sinister person. I consider Mr. Lowry to be an evil man."
她去找了警察。她来到了我们的办公室。她揭露了洛瑞先生向她做出却又打破的承诺。洛瑞先生得到的金钱回报是惊人的。这是莫林警察局的肯尼斯·雷克斯罗斯中尉。他已经关注唐·洛瑞多年了。他打发走了许多来到警察局寻找天使的男士，他一直在寻找关押唐的方法。他非常恶毒。他是个阴险的人。我认为洛瑞先生是一个邪恶的人。"
But thanks to Susan Rassow, the police finally had evidence to obtain subpoenas. They raided Don's print shop. They found out that some men sold everything in order to give their life savings to the angels. One man lived out of his car and forwarded his social security check to his angel. When the police got in touch with these guys, many of them realized for the first time that their treasured letters were written by a man. Well, what I was turned out to be angry about and more embarrassed about more than anything was the fact that he was even involved and any man at all was even involved.
但多亏了苏珊·拉索斯，警方终于有了获取传票的证据。他们突击搜查了唐的印刷厂。他们发现有些男人卖掉了所有东西，只为了把他们一生的积蓄交给天使。一个男人住在车里，把他收到的社保支票转寄给他的天使。当警察联系上这些家伙时，他们中的许多人第一次意识到他们珍视的信件是一个男人写的。嗯，我感到愤怒和尴尬的地方，比什么都多的是，甚至卷入其中这件事本身，以及任何男人竟然卷入其中。
Again, this is Ken Blanchard, who spent years receiving letters from Angel Vanessa. When I found out that these letters I'd been getting all these times and I thought it was some girl sharing something with me, well then I find find out is him writing the darn thing. You know, I thought, my God, what the hell am I getting into? But I can laugh about now, but I think at the time I did have some feelings about that. They weren't very charitable. Don's lawyer said that if members believed the angels were real, that was on them. As Don told me many years later, People believe what they want to believe.
再次声明，这是肯·布兰查德，他花了多年时间接收来自天使凡妮莎的信件。当我发现我一直收到的这些信件——我以为是某个女孩在和我分享一些东西——然后我发现是他在写这些鬼东西。你知道，我心想，天哪，我到底卷入了什么鬼地方？不过我现在可以笑出来了，但我想当时我确实对此有一些感觉。它们并不怎么仁慈。唐的律师说，如果会员们相信天使是真的，那是他们自己的问题。正如唐多年后对我说的那样：人们相信他们想要相信的。
You cannot dissuade them. Most members believe the angels lived forever and a never-never land called to retreat. They told me they lived forever and they never grew old. Does that tell you anything? Huh? Well, you're surprised that they believed you? Yeah. It has helped them, I mean, it made them happy, so big deal.
你无法劝阻他们。大多数会员相信天使永远生活在一个叫做隐居地的永无乡里。他们告诉我他们永远活着，而且从不老去。这能说明什么吗？啊？嗯，你很惊讶他们相信了你？对。这帮助了他们，我的意思是，这让他们快乐，所以没什么大不了的。
Don and Pamela were charged with male fraud, conspiracy, and money laundering. The press mobbed the trial. Don was shamed in the press, called a snake oil salesman at People magazine. Which brings me back to what got me interested in the story in the first place. The thing that really surprised me. Many members flew from all over the country to show up at the courthouse in defense of the call. Some stood outside with picket science defending the brotherhood.
唐和帕梅拉被控邮件欺诈、阴谋罪和洗钱罪。记者们蜂拥而至挤满了审判现场。唐在媒体中受尽羞辱，在《人物》杂志上被称作卖蛇油的江湖骗子。这让我回到了最初让我对这个故事感兴趣的事情上。真正让我惊讶的事情。许多会员从全国各地飞来，出现在法院外为邪教辩护。一些人拿着纠察标语站在外面捍卫兄弟会。
Jesse and his friend Al were both there. As they waited outside the courtroom, Jesse saw Pamela come up. He rushed over to her. She was walking up and I noticed she was cold, so I took off my jacket and draped it over her shoulders, and we walked all the way up to the courthouse. I was kind of like a security guard and after she went indoors I took my coat off and I backed off and everything. Did she say anything to you at that point?
杰西和他的朋友艾尔都在场。当他们在法庭外等候时，杰西看到帕梅拉走了过来。他冲了过去。她走过来时，我注意到她很冷，所以我脱下夹克披在她的肩膀上，我们一起走到了法院大楼。我有点像个保安，等她走进室内后，我脱下外套退了回去。她当时对你说了什么吗？
No, not really. Members testified on the stand and said the call had been a critical, beautiful part of their lives. One man said letters from the angel saved him from alcoholism and thoughts of suicide. Jesse testified, too. This is him reading a court transcript of what he said on the stand. Well, it gave you, like I said, inspiration to continue, no matter what the circumstances that you were going through, that if you preserved, you could make it. Do you remember saying this at the trial?
没有，真的没有。会员们在证人席上作证说，这个邪教曾是他们生活中至关重要、美好的一部分。一个男人说来自天使的信件拯救了他，让他免于酗酒和自杀的念头。杰西也作证了。这是他朗读法庭记录，关于他在证人席上所说的话。嗯，它给了你，就像我说的，继续下去的灵感，无论你经历什么环境，只要你坚持下去，你就能成功。你记得在审判时说过这些吗？
Yes, I do. Would you say that you still stand by what you said at trial? Yes. So here's the thing, Jesse. You know, Don Lowry liked to you and sent you letters on behalf of someone else for many years. And you formed an emotional connection with this woman who was writing to you,
是的，我记得。你会说你仍然坚持你在审判时说过的话吗？是的。所以事情是这样的，杰西。你知道，唐·洛瑞欺骗了你，多年来一直代表别人给你写信。而你对这个给你写信的女人建立了情感联系，
when at the same time, you showed up at trial to essentially defend Don Lowry, and I'm trying to understand how and why you did that. Well, like I said before, it wasn't actually defending him, but it was actually Pamela that was the one that we were all we turned our attention to help her and that meant helping Dawn also when everything. I understand that Dawn was really the mastermind of the operation, but when she showed up at these meetings and she presented herself as the same Pamela who was the Pamela and the letters,
然而与此同时，你却出现在审判现场，基本上是为了捍卫唐·洛瑞，我在努力理解你当时是如何以及为什么要那样做的。嗯，就像我之前说的，这其实不是在捍卫他，而是帕梅拉才是我们所有人把注意力转向去帮助的那个人，而这意味着同时也要帮助唐。我明白唐实际上是整个行动的幕后策划者，但当她出现在这些聚会上，并将自己表现为信中那个帕梅拉时……
wasn't she lying to you? Well, I guess you could think about that that way, yes. Did you ever think about it that way? I know, not until now and everything, where all of this has been re-broad out and everything. Don and Pamela were both found guilty. Pamela served two years in prison. Don was in prison for ten years. When I met Don, I asked him whether he felt he did anything wrong. I think I did something very wrong. I suppose I made it a little bit too real. I did. I made
难道她不是在对你撒谎吗？好吧，我想你可以这么认为，是的。你曾经从这个角度想过吗？我知道，直到现在，当所有这些事情都被重新翻出来的时候才想到。唐和帕梅拉都被判定有罪。帕梅拉在监狱里服刑两年。唐在监狱里呆了十年。当我遇到唐时，我问他是否觉得自己做了什么错事。我想我确实做了一件非常错的事。我想我把它变得太真实了一点。我确实这么做了。我把它
it too real. Jesse lives alone now with his dog, Chubaka. He's in his 60s and is still single. He sat some complications from diabetes recently and had parts of his foot amputated. It hasn't been easy. My producer, Stephanie Foo, visited him at his house in Texas. I was in the hospital after my amputation running around on my knee scooter. Said, you can still do this, keep going and everything. So, remember those words she told me, get on your feet. So, I do that and everything and keep going. Wow.
变得太真实了。杰西现在和他的狗楚巴卡独自生活。他已经六十多岁了，仍然单身。他最近有一些糖尿病并发症，脚部的一些部位被截肢了。这并不容易。我的制作人斯蒂芬妮·富去他在德克萨斯州的家中探望了他。我截肢后在医院里用膝盖滑板到处跑。她说，你还能做到这一点，继续前进什么的。所以，记住她对我说的话，站起来。所以我照做了，继续前进。哇。
Even now, even today. Even today and everything and stuff. So, but basically that line, you know, get on your feet. It doesn't really matter who wrote it. No. You think back, but it brings back fond memories of way back when and you could be in your hundreds and everything or older and I hope to have this,
即使在现在，甚至在今天。甚至在今天以及各种事情。所以，基本上那句台词，你知道的，站起来。是谁写的其实并不重要。不。你回想起来，但这勾起了对过去的美好回忆，你可能已经上百岁了，或者更老，我希望拥有这个，
I'm a mind on down the line and everything and stuff. So. Jesse still has the little wooden lighthouse Pamela sent him. It's on his dresser in his bedroom. And he still has two photos of Pamela and his Dan, one on the wall, one on his desk. In one, she's sitting in an office chair, hands in her lap, not glamorous or sexy or anything. Jesse says, she's just sitting there being herself.
我的思绪会一直延续下去。所以。杰西仍然留着帕梅拉送给他的那个小木制灯塔。它放在他卧室的梳妆台上。他依然保留着两张帕梅拉和他的照片，一张在墙上，一张在书桌上。其中一张里，她坐在办公椅上，双手放在腿上，并不迷人或性感，什么都没有。杰西说，她只是坐在那里做她自己。
It's just a little something to say. I made a friend. Don Lowry got what he wanted from his con. Money and lots of it. But it turns out that many forgiers are not motivated by the bottom line. They're really after a windfall that is psychological. If I'm allowed to have a favorite forger which I know sounds a little bit funny it would be Eric Hebern who's really the Prince of Art Forgers. This is Noah
这只是一个小小的暗示，说明我交到了一个朋友。唐·洛里从他的骗局中得到了他想要的东西。钱，而且是大量的钱。但事实证明，许多造假者并不是为了金钱利益而动。他们真正追求的是一种心理上的意外之财。如果允许我有我最喜欢的造假者——我知道这听起来有点滑稽——那一定是埃里克·赫本，他真的是艺术造假之王。这是诺亚
Charney, he's the author of the Art of Forgery. In his book, he writes about the Forger, Eric Hebern. And his story is one of revenge over monetary gain. That's why he turned to Forgery. He initially had been a failed artist. He couldn't get traction with his own original artworks, even though he had some serious talent. And he had been at a flea market and he purchased some drawings that he thought might be of value. He brought them to an art gallery in London. And the gallery said, you know, this is pretty good. I'll take it off your hands, not bad. So he sold them and he made a profit so he was quite pleased. But then he came back past the gallery a little bit later and saw that it was in the window, the very object he had sold, for much more than he had paid, and he felt that he had been essentially
查尼，他是《艺术造假》一书的作者。在他的书中，他写到了造假者埃里克·赫本。他的故事是一个关于复仇而非金钱利益的故事。这就是他转向造假的原因。他最初是一个失败的艺术家。他的原创艺术作品无法获得关注，尽管他有着很高的天赋。他在跳蚤市场买了一些他认为可能有价值的画作。他把它们带到伦敦的一家艺术画廊。画廊的人说，你知道，这挺不错的。我收下了，还不错。于是他卖掉了它们并赚了一笔钱，所以他感到非常高兴。但随后他过了一会儿又回到了这家画廊，看到他卖掉的那件物品正摆在橱窗里，售价比他买的时候高得多，他觉得他基本上被
swindled by the gallery and decided to get revenge. When we come back, we find out how this con artist went about getting his revenge. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is NPR. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. This hour is all about fakery, forgery, and the psychology of the Khan. Noah Charni is the author of the art of forgery. Before the break, he told us about the painter,
画廊给坑了，于是决定进行报复。广告回来后，我们将揭晓这个骗子是如何进行报复的。欢迎收听《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是NPR。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这一小时我们主要讨论虚假、造假以及骗子的心理学。诺亚·查尼是《艺术造假》的作者。在广告之前，他给我们讲述了画家
Eric Hebern, who failed to get the art world to take him seriously. Ayas Noah, about the decision Eric Hebern made, to get revenge. The decision was to try to make his own drawings in the style of old masters and try to pass them off as originals. And by doing so, he gains a sort of passive-aggressive revenge that
埃里克·赫本的故事，他未能让艺术界认真对待他。我问诺亚关于埃里克·赫本为复仇而做出的决定。这个决定是尝试模仿古代大师的风格创作自己的画作，并试图将它们蒙混过关当作真迹。通过这样做，他获得了一种被动攻击性的复仇，
is the primary initial motivation for the majority of art foragers in this book. And there are two components to it. On the one hand, if he creates a drawing, and the experts think that it's by a great master, then he can convince himself that he must be as good as the master. But the second part is that if he's able to fool these so-called experts, he demonstrates how foolish they are, and the implication is that they were foolish not to endorse his own original artworks. When Hepburn decided to forge the great masters, he decided to do it in a way that was quite unique. What was that way?
这也是这本书中大多数艺术造假者最初的主要动机。它有两个组成部分。一方面，如果他创作了一幅画，而专家们认为这是一位伟大大师的作品，那么他就可以说服自己，他一定和大师一样优秀。但第二部分是，如果他能够愚弄这些所谓的专家，他就展示了这些专家有多么愚蠢，其潜台词是，他们没有认可他自己的原创艺术作品是愚蠢的。当赫本决定伪造大师作品时，他决定以一种非常独特的方式来进行。那是怎样的方式呢？
The majority of successful art foragers in the 20th century use variations on what I call a provenance trap. And the essential component is it uses provenance or the documented history of an object as a trap to lure the researcher to authenticate the work. Let's be honest, every art historian wants to be Indiana Jones and wants to find lost treasures. And you may or may not know that the majority of works that we know of made by old masters are lost. In some cases, as much as two thirds of the Eur of these famous artists of the Renaissance, we know of them
20世纪大多数成功的艺术造假者都在使用我称之为“出处陷阱”的变体。其核心要素是利用出处或物品的有据可查的历史作为诱饵，诱使研究人员对作品进行鉴定。老实说，每个艺术史学家都想成为印第安纳·琼斯，都想找到失落的宝藏。你可能知道也可能不知道，我们所知道的大多数由古代大师创作的作品都失踪了。在某些情况下，这些文艺复兴时期著名艺术家多达三分之二的作品，我们是通过
through documented references to them, but we don't know where they are. So Providence Trap uses documented history and then creates lost works that match the real documented history. And Eric Hebron is an example of that. He very cleverly would create what appeared to be these preparatory drawings for works like, the one I'm looking at in the book right now, Anthony Van Dyke's, crowning with thorns, which is in the Museo del Prado and Madrid. He created what looked like a drawing in preparation for that, and we know logically that Van Dyke made lots of preparatory drawings, but they simply aren't extant anymore.
对它们的文献记载才知道它们的存在的，但我们不知道它们在哪里。因此，“出处陷阱”利用有据可查的历史，然后创造出符合真实文献记载的失落作品。埃里克·赫本就是这样一个例子。他非常聪明地创作出看似这些作品的预备草图，比如我现在在书中看到的这幅，安东尼·范·戴克的《荆棘冠冕》，这幅画藏于马德里的普拉多博物馆。他创作了一幅看起来像是为该作品做准备的草图，按常理我们知道范·戴克做过很多预备草图，但它们确实已经不复存在了。
I wonder if you could just walk me through these two drawings that I'm looking at in the book here. I'm seeing the original on my left hand side and I'm seeing Heberne's preparatory drawing for this work on the right. What am I seeing here in Anthony Van Dyke's crowning with Thorns? In the original painting, which was finished around 1620, is an oil on canvas. It's a substantial size and it shows Christ having the crown of Thorns lowered on him as he's bound and he's surrounded by people who would have been his torturers and he seems resigned to his fate and it's very beautiful, it's very glossy, there's brilliant use of oil paints, you can have an almost sculptural quality to Christ's body. There are a number of figures, there's one, two, three, four, five figures
我想知道你能不能带我看一下书中这两幅画。我左边看到的是原作，右边看到的是赫本为这幅作品画的预备草图。在这幅安东尼·范·戴克的《荆棘冠冕》中，我看到了什么？这幅创作于1620年左右的原作是一幅布面油画。它的尺寸很大，描绘了基督被捆绑着，头戴荆棘冠冕垂下的情景，他周围都是他的行刑者，他似乎对自己的命运逆来顺受，画面非常优美，极具光泽，油画颜料的运用十分巧妙，基督的身体甚至带有一种雕塑般的质感。画面中有好几个人物，背景里有
in the background including people peering in through a graded window in the back to spy on what's happening, and Christ has seated quite comfortably facing front out to the viewer. Now, when we turn to the preparatory drawing, the positioning of the figures and the number of the figures is different, but this is entirely normal. Artists, when they're coming up with the concept or invention of the artwork, will do various
一、二、三、四、五个面孔，包括从后面的格栅窗向外窥探以监视发生的事情的人，而基督则十分舒适地坐着，正面面向观众。现在，当我们转向预备草图时，人物的定位和数量都不同了，但这完全是正常的。艺术家在构思或创造艺术作品时，会画各种
sketches to try to get a composition that they like. In fact, it would be suspicious if there was a drawing that looked exactly like the finished product. But here you have this idea that Christ is leaning far to the side, as being physically supported by one of his executioners, as another one pushes the crown of thorns more violently onto his head. It's more dynamic, and there's more movement to it, more diagonals. And it essentially looks like an initial concept that you decided not to follow through
草图来尝试获得他们喜欢的构图。事实上，如果有一张草图看起来跟最终成品一模一样，那反而会令人起疑。但在这里，你会看到这样一种构想：基督身体大大向一侧倾斜，由其中一个行刑者在身体上支撑着，而另一个人则更加暴力地把荆棘冠冕往他头上推。它更具动感，有更多的运动感和更多的对角线。它基本上看起来像是一个最初的构想，你决定不在最终的画作中
with for this drawing. It's very clever because it's not hitting you over the head with the fact that this must be preparatory drawing. What I find really, really clever about this was that when Hepburn is basically presenting a preparatory drawing that looks actually quite different from the finished drawing, he's allowing the expert to connect the dots. That is psychologically very clever because he's taking advantage of the fact the expert has vanity and wants to make these connections and the best con game is where the mark essentially
沿用这个想法。这非常聪明，因为它并没有直接生硬地告诉你这一定是一幅预备草图。我觉得这最绝、最聪明的地方在于，当赫本基本上呈现出一幅与最终画作成品实际大不相同的预备草图时，他是在允许专家自己去串联线索。从心理学上讲，这非常聪明，因为他利用了专家带有虚荣心、想要建立这些联系的心理，而最好的骗局就是让受害者基本上
executes the con for you. But the second thing was, by so doing, he's also demonstrating to himself that the expert really is not an expert. It's true, it's very clever on his part, and the majority of successful fordras use some variation on the theme that you describe. They set a trap without being too specific and allow the experts to dive headfirst into it and enthusiastically authenticate the work because it feels to them like a great discovery that they are making personally. And once an expert goes out on a limb and says, this is authentic, it is very hard for them to go back on it. So they wind up tangling themselves in this net that's been laid out by the forger.
自己为你完成这个骗局。但第二点是，通过这样做，他也向自己证明了这位专家确实不是专家。没错，这体现了他的高明之处，大多数成功的造假者都会使用你所描述的这种主题的变体。他们设下一个并不那么具体的陷阱，任由专家一头扎进去，并热情洋溢地鉴定作品的真伪，因为这在他们看来是他们亲自做出的重大发现。一旦某个专家冒险表态说这是真的，他们就很难再反悔了。因此，他们最终会作茧自缚，陷入造假者布下的这张网中。
We've been talking to Noah Charney, he's the author of the art of forgery. Ayasnella about forger Eric Hebern's extraordinary attention to detail. Well, Hebern was particularly meticulous. Getting the technique right is something that you can do essentially by practice. Getting the materials correct is much harder and it's more expensive. It is also not strictly necessary because most forgers that I looked at got the style just about right. They had a very clever provenance trap and they didn't really need to get the materials correct because it's not normal for objects to be friends that they tested unless some red flag is raised stylistically or in terms of
我们一直在与《艺术造假》一书的作者诺亚·查尼对话。我问诺亚关于造假者埃里克·赫本对细节的非凡关注。嗯，赫本特别一丝不苟。把技术练好基本上通过练习是可以做到的。把材料弄对要困难得多，而且成本更高。这也不是绝对必要的，因为我研究过的大多数造假者都把风格把握得差不多。他们有一个非常巧妙的出处陷阱，他们实际上不需要把材料弄对，因为正常情况下，除非在风格上或
the object's history nobody does forensic testing. This is part of a residual gentleman's agreement in the art trade that dates back hundreds of years that if an expert says it's good it's good then it's good. There really has to be something very wrong for them to forensically test it. Or maybe the experts disagree. Or if the experts disagree, if they can't reach a consensus, then the tiebreaker is broken by scientific testing. These days, it doesn't have to be the case. Forensic testing is neither particularly expensive nor is it invasive necessarily into the object. But Hebern took that level of detail
物品的历史方面出现红旗警示，否则没有人会对物品进行法医检测。这是艺术品交易中数百年来延续下来的不成文君子协定的一部分，即如果专家说它是真的，那就是真的，那么它就是真的。必须要有什么严重的问题，他们才会对其进行法医检测。或者专家们意见不一。或者如果专家们意见不一，无法达成共识，那么决定胜负的关键就是科学检测。如今，情况已经不必如此了。法医检测既不是特别昂贵，也不一定对物品具有破坏性。但赫本却达到了那样的细节高度，
because he was a perfectionist, because he loved what he was doing, he was very passionate about it, and because I think he wanted to genuinely feel that he was doing exactly what the old masters were doing. It is so interesting that he spent so much time thinking about his technique, but also thinking about what he needed to do to himself in order to be able to pull off these forgeries. What did he do? Well he's a real character and he volunteered all of his secrets because he was looking for notoriety and he wrote a book called The Art Forger's Handbook, which incidentally
因为他是一个完美主义者，因为他热爱他所做的事情，他对之充满热情，而且因为我认为他想真切地感受到自己正在做的事情与古代大师所做的事情完全一样。非常有趣的是，他花了很多时间思考自己的技术，同时也思考为了能够成功实施这些伪造，他需要对自己做些什么。他做了什么？嗯，他是个真正有个性的人，他自愿透露了自己所有的秘密，因为他在寻找声誉，他写了一本书叫《艺术造假者手册》，顺便说一句，
has been found in the studio of many an art forger rested since it came out. And one of his tricks was to get drunk. He would get drunk while he was making the drawings, and it would achieve a certain fluidity of line and body. He would not overthink things. You wouldn't have the mental or physical capacity if you drink enough to be too painstaking about it. And a painstaking line is a giveaway to an expert
这本书自出版以来，在许多被捕的艺术造假者的工作室里都能找到。他的技巧之一就是喝醉。他在画画时会喝醉，这会使线条和身体达到某种流畅度。他不会过度思考。如果你喝得够多，你就没有足够的精神或体力去锱铢必较。而一笔一画精雕细琢的线条会向专家暴露
that's something funny's going on. He would do dozens of sketches to prepare the fluidity of line he was after, but then he would start drinking heavily and then do his sketches as well in order to ensure that he wouldn't overthink things. I'm really intrigued by the idea that the motivation for so many of these forgers, Hebron included, is not money. Clearly you would think that the financial value, the forger is deriving, it has to be a big part of it, and I'm really intrigued by the idea that it's really a psychological motivation that comes first.
出有些不对劲。他会做几十张草图来培养他所追求的线条流畅度，但随后他会开始大喝特喝，然后一边喝酒一边画草图，以确保自己不会想得太多。我对这样一个观点非常感兴趣：许多造假者（包括赫本在内）的动机其实不是钱。显然你会认为经济价值、造假者从中获取的利益一定占很大一部分，但我对这样一个观点很感兴趣，即真正的首要动机其实是心理上的。
It's true. The reason that many forgers continue into a career of forgery is eventually they realize this is a source of income, but that initial motivation is this passive-aggressive revenge. However, there's a caveat here because the revenge is a private victory until you're caught. The reason is that they have to enjoy this revenge entirely in private until somebody discovers them. But the moment they're discovered, then all of a sudden they are shown as a great artist and they have publicly shamed the experts who they were out to shame when they set out.
确实如此。许多造假者之所以将造假生涯持续下去，是因为他们最终意识到这是一笔收入来源，但最初的动机是这种被动攻击性的复仇。然而，这里有一个注意事项，因为在被抓到之前，复仇只是一种私下的胜利。原因在于，在别人发现他们之前，他们必须完全在私下里享受这种复仇。但一旦他们被发现，紧接着他们就被展现为一位伟大的艺术家，并且他们公开羞辱了那些他们在着手时想要羞辱的专家。
So, this is the completion, the self-actualization is only when they're caught. A lot of these foragers actually inserted what one forger by the name of Tom Keating called Time Bombs, and these are intentionally inserted anachronisms that could be used if the forger chooses to announce that the work is a forgery even if no one would otherwise believe him. One of my favorite stories is a German forger named Lothar Malskott who was a Restorer of medieval frescoes just after the Second World War and he was commissioned to restore frescoes in a church that had been damaged by Allied bombs, but when he got there He found that the frescoes in a church that had been damaged by Allied bombs. But when he got there, he found that the frescoes were so badly destroyed there was nothing
所以，这是圆满，自我实现只发生在他们被抓到的时候。许多造假者实际上塞入了被一位名叫汤姆·基廷的造假者称为“定时炸弹”的东西，这些是故意插入的时代错误，如果造假者选择公开宣称该作品是伪造的，即使别人怎么也不会相信，这些也可以派上用场。我最喜欢的故事之一是一个名叫洛塔尔·马尔斯科特的德国造假者，他是第二次世界大战后中世纪湿壁画的修复师，他受托修复一座被盟军炸弹损坏的教堂里的湿壁画，但当他到达那里时，
he could do, and the photographs in the archives didn't show enough to reproduce it. But that didn't stop when we decided to make his own medieval frescoes. And when they were revealed it was a big national sensation, so much so that the German government printed 4 million postage stamps with a detail from the frescoes on it. But he didn't want this private victory. He wanted to get credit for what he had done and nobody believed him. So he took the very unusual step of suing himself so that he could have the public forum of a courtroom in which to argue his case that he was the artist of these frescoes. He was both a prosecutor and the defendant. He was. It's a very weird case in legal history and still nobody believed him and Hilly pointed out two time bombs that he had inserted intentionally in case no one believed him. One was a turkey. Turkey's
他发现教堂里的湿壁画损毁得如此严重，以至于他无能为力，而档案中的照片也没有显示出足够的信息来进行复制。但这并没有阻止他决定创作自己的中世纪湿壁画。当它们被揭幕时，引起了巨大的全国轰动，以至于德国政府印制了400万枚带有该湿壁画局部细节的邮票。但他并不想要这种私下的胜利。他想要为自己所做的事情获得认可，但没有人相信他。于是他采取了一个非常不同寻常的举动——起诉自己，以便能够拥有一个法庭的公开论坛，在其中争辩说他是这些湿壁画的艺术家。他既是原告又是被告。他是的。这是法律史上一个非常诡异的案子，而且依然没有人相信他，直到他指出他故意塞进去的两枚定时炸弹，以防没有人相信他。一个是火鸡。火鸡
are indigenous to North America and there would have been no turkeys in 13th century Germany. And second was Marlene Dietrich, whose portrait was hidden in the background and she definitely wasn't around in the 13th century. So this is so interesting because of course when you think about stories about swashbuckling robin hoods, the leaving behind a motif in your crime that you rob a bank and you leave behind a white glove or you rob something else and you leave behind the same white glove, the desire to leave a stamp on what it is that you have done changes to some ways from the world of just straightforward crime where you really want to cover your tracks completely to something quite different.
原产于北美，13世纪的德国不可能有火鸡。第二个是玛琳·黛德丽，她的肖像藏在背景中，而她绝对不可能出现在13世纪。所以这非常有趣，因为当然，当你想到关于侠盗罗宾汉的故事时，你在犯罪现场留下一个特定的标志——比如你抢劫了一家银行，留下了一只白手套；或者你抢劫了别的东西，留下了同样的白手套——这种想要在你的所作所为上留下印记的渴望，在某种程度上从那种真正想要彻底掩盖行踪的单纯犯罪世界，转变为了完全不同的东西。
One of the issues here and the reason that forgers are quite happy to be caught in the end is that forgers tend to get very low sentences. Some of them don't even go to jail at all. From a public perspective, there is no fear of art foragers. If you go to a cocktail party, and I whisper to you that this intriguing looking gentleman in the corner is a Ponzi Schumer. You would say, oh, I don't want anything to do with him. However, if I say he's an art forager, you'd be intrigued, you'd probably head straight over and start chatting. I would.
这里的问题之一，也是造假者最终很乐意被抓的原因，在于造假者往往会得到非常轻的判刑。其中一些人甚至根本不用进监狱。从公众的角度来看，人们对艺术造假者并没有恐惧。如果你去参加一个鸡尾酒会，我悄悄告诉你，角落里这个看起来很迷人的绅士是一个庞氏骗局策划者。你可能会说，哦，我可不想跟他扯上任何关系。然而，如果我说他是一个艺术造假者，你会被吸引住，可能会径直走过去开始聊天。我会的。
They're non-threatening, they're not scary, and there's something to admire in them. Is it possible, though, that Hebron's desire for revenge and the psychological forces that were driving him kept him from accomplishing what might have actually been his life's work? It's entirely possible, but on the other hand, I think that he would say that his life's work shifted to being the greatest art forger in history. And I think he could make a good case for that.
他们并不具有威胁性，并不可怕，在他们身上总有一些值得钦佩的地方。不过，赫本对复仇的渴望以及驱使他的心理力量，是否有可能阻碍了他去实现本可能成为他毕生杰作的东西呢？完全有可能，但另一方面，我认为他会说，他毕生的杰作已经转变为成为历史上最伟大的艺术造假者。而且我认为他完全有理由这么说。
And he's in good company. There are art forgers in my book who include Michelangelo, Luca Giordano, Mark Antonio Ramondi, very famous Renaissance artists who also dabbled in forgery, and he is up there in terms of his physical ability to reproduce another artist's style, the care that he put in both the concept of playing with the artist's existing ovra and reproducing the materials in an accurate way. He is a genius, but he's a genius at art forgery, and I don't think it
而且他并不孤单。我书中的艺术造假者包括米开朗基罗、卢卡·焦尔达诺、马尔坎托尼奥·雷蒙迪，这些都是非常著名的文艺复兴时期艺术家，他们也涉足过造假，他在重现另一位艺术家的风格的物理能力、在玩转艺术家现有作品概念以及以准确方式复制材料方面所付出的心血上，都位居前列。他是个天才，但他是在艺术造假方面的天才，而且我不认为
panned out as a genius of original artistry. Noah Charney, I want to thank you for talking with me today. This has been a pleasure. Thanks for having me. Noa Charney is the author of the Art of Forgery, the Minds, Motives and Methods of Master Forgeurs. When you look at a masterpiece, you aren't just looking at paint on canvas. You're thinking about Monet's hand holding the paintbrush.
这能作为原创艺术天才而取得成功。诺亚·查尼，我想感谢你今天与我交谈。这真是一段愉快的时光。谢谢邀请我。诺亚·查尼是《艺术造假：艺术造假大师的心智、动机与手法》一书的作者。当你看着一件杰作时，你不仅仅是在看画布上的颜料。你在想着莫奈拿着画笔的手。
You're thinking about history, the passage of time. The meaning of a painting is tied up in what you, the viewer, bring to it. This is what made Eric Heberne and Don Lowry so successful. They both understood that a con game requires technical skill. But much more important, a successful con involves a deep understanding of human nature. The art experts that Eric Heberne duped wanted to believe they had made a grand discovery. Jesse wanted to believe that against all odds, love had walked into his life.
你在想着历史，时间的流逝。一幅画的意义与你——观赏者——带给它的东西息息相关。这就是让埃里克·赫本和唐·洛里如此成功的原因。他们都明白，骗局需要技术技能。但更重要的是，一个成功的骗局需要对人性有深刻的理解。埃里克·赫本愚弄的艺术专家们想要相信他们有了一次伟大的发现。杰西想要相信，历经重重困难，爱情已经走进他的生活。
Prosecutors can take con men and fordures to court, try them, and get them sentenced to prison. But the real drivers of con games and fordures to court, try them and get them sentenced to prison. But the real drivers of con games can't be brought to trial. They are the psychological hungers that lie within all of us. Loneliness, ambition, hope. This week's show was produced by Lucy Perkins, Stephanie Fu and Karam Agar-Kallison. A team includes Tara Boyle, Jenny Schmidt, Raina Cohen, Parts Shah, Laura Correll and Thomas Lu. For more hidden brain, please follow us on Facebook, Twitter and Instagram.
检察官可以将骗子和造假者告上法庭，审判他们并判处他们监禁。但骗局和造假者背后的真正驱动力是无法被送上法庭审判的。它们是我们所有人内心深处的心理饥渴。孤独、野心、希望。本期节目由露西·帕金斯、斯蒂芬妮·富和卡拉姆·阿加尔-卡利森制作。团队成员包括塔拉·博伊尔、珍妮·施密特、雷娜·科恩、帕茨·沙、劳拉·科雷尔和托马斯·鲁。更多《隐藏的大脑》内容，请在脸书、推特和Instagram上关注我们。
Please also subscribe to our podcast on iTunes or the NPR-1 app or wherever you get your podcasts. I'm Shankar Vedantum, see you next week. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
也请在iTunes、NPR-1应用或您获取播客的任何地方订阅我们的播客。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆，我们下周见。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。